oh man mods are the word also apply job
bro it's incoming oh good yeah all right
supply drops guys new thing we're gonna
get to experience one hopefully day man
we got some lughnasa water I don't care
about the loot I'm care about the
content amen oh the drop is close to us
or wait what it can go to multiple areas
wait are there multiple supply drops no
I just see one no but like if you look
at the map there's like four of them no
no I just see this one look come to me
to see this one flashing one I mean we
gotta a so okay so how this works Rob
yeah is that um it's not contaminated so
the moment we get it we just get the
loot also I think what we want to do is
just pop our alt and then try to pick it
up or something well because the AI
apparently can pick it up to oh the
supply drops their [ __ ] is under attack
by bricks and some other Joker
is it still there he's always hear me it
no there's no no no we are too slow well
no do Wow and I just ain't [ __ ] load of
damage from that thing Wow blows up to
do we want to kill us to wait there's
another drop that's what out here you
are right okay I only saw one I didn't
see that one okay yeah I marked the
other one you see it yeah that's kind of
cool there's like more than one how far
is that do we have to keep going
anything we do yeah i mean i said at
what point we're all right you see it
see it to the left oh that mob you might
take the supply job and we level not
he's extracting yeah but supply drops
like right near I'm like why wouldn't
you do both things I'm gonna pop alts
like right when we get there kill the
dudes and then hopefully we can just
grab the loot we're all be ready it's
time oh [ __ ] my alters not oh good call
wasn't even looking this brown dude he's
getting in my face this don't shoot in
front of all right I'm gonna grab the
loot you get those guys off me I'm
coming whatever I'm taking it I got
division tech and purples what purpose
oh this guy's face jeez that's not good
job oh that damn thing explodes